i think um the franchise has never seen
someone like the loud before when it
comes to like having a successful black
meal who is
not dependent on getting a k1 pizza to
come to america who has his own i think
if he was a different race i'm sorry i
don't think it would have been that bad
because it would have been like yeah
that's expected you know you know but
seeing this it's like oh this is not
common for us um you never heard me you
know yell at my wife you never heard me
cuss at me but you know to hear certain
things like oh man this is the worst
person ever like those things like wow
really you know um
you know it's like because i don't like
water on the floor
you know it's it's you know it's it's
it's interesting but it's also you know
things that you have to look at yourself
in the mirror and say okay well all
right let me try to do some things
differently go for it
i have never made a snow angel good job
you like my guardian angel
don't mess it up don't mess it up
oh my god
i like it
i'm bilal i'm 43 years old and this is
my wife
shaida
nice
shada and
first of all how are you two it's been a
journey how are you doing
we are doing great like we are we are
good it's so good well i'll be honest
i'm surprised to see you two unhappily
ever after but you received a lot of
criticism so i just
you know expected you to be done
what made you come back
beautiful first
yeah
i think it's because we have
real problems that everybody can relate
to you know there's always the
ups and downs and i think it's because
our issues just like
regular people issues we're dealing with
mature problems here you know in a
relationship wanted to have children
my handsome husband you know he loves
kids but he wants to like just enjoy
life for some more time and i know i'm
pressing on that so i think a lot of
women in society could relate to our
story and you know we have so much
things surrounded our story dude i asked
it so i think that is one of the
elements that
people could relate to so that's why we
are back on happily ever after yeah
how are you feeling black cause you're
the one who has gone through the fire
um you know she she tends to get
whatever she wants it's so funny because
people think i'm in control
she controls everything so uh whatever
she wants i obey and i obliged so she
wanted to come back and
i wish it's my command you okay man
i don't know i feel like here i am just
thinking i'm this good guy but it seems
like
everybody sees it different you know
didn't feel good
after the 90 day fiance tello blah
you're feeling down on yourself
due to the criticism how are you feeling
now
um you know it was it was um
it was interesting it was really amazing
you know um
you know you because you know you know a
lot that what you do and what i have
done for
just you know people life and you know
community efforts etc
and then just kind of put in a small
little box and you know you know talk
about the
the settle you know the little things
that you know sometimes we kind of focus
on those negative and bad things that we
all have
so you know when you hear all those
things coming to you you know it could
it could it could do some things to you
know can bring you down but you know um
i'm a positive person i'm an optimistic
person you know and i always try to look
at the bright side you know
try to look in the mirror and try to you
know think about things that i can
improve on as a person because we know i
know we all have it i know it's quick to
point the finger but
um i try to look at myself first for
most you know
yeah i think one of my biggest regrets
um after seeing that tell was not
standing up for my husband i think i
should have
speak i could have been a little bit
more vocal to highlight some of the good
stuff as well as you know little things
that we go through here and there but i
felt like when i looked back at that i
was like i will never be so silent again
in my life anytime someone has to
address him like if it's like more than
one person talking i'm gonna like stop
that immediately and try to like defend
him as much as i can so i didn't know
how that looked for me as a wife i was
completely embarrassed like i thought i
didn't pick up for him as much well
below you said you were getting in the
tool [ __ ]
i gotta go to the two shed and and get
to work
the toolshed and get to work what are
some of the things that you
you know realize you need to work on
oh you know
like
you know she always when it comes to max
playing and you're very cautious when it
comes to that you don't lecture as much
by the way really i was gonna that was
gonna be my next question yeah
well you know i think um
we we men sometimes we get labeled with
mansplaining and lecture and things like
that
and a lot of times we try to come from a
good place so those are the things that
i'm definitely trying to work on i'm i'm
an email so you know use of speaking
i've been a speaker for multiple years
speaking about real estate investing and
financial literacy you know all around
the country so i'm used to speaking so
those are the things that i have to like
you know turn down sometimes when right
because also my wife
knowing that she
you know she's not your i guess you're
regular american you know 37 now and 38
yeah uh year old so there's a lot i'm
trying to also educate her and a teacher
and trying to get up to speed and
they'll teach her a lot of different
things so it can come off that way and
those are the things that i have to like
you know
just kind of like you know okay try not
to do and you know but there are things
that you know i'm trying to i i see more
of the husband when he comes home like
when he comes to me was still in that
you know speaking mood but no i'm seeing
nothing he's trying to catch himself
because i give him the look i was like
you're doing it again and he's like okay
dave let me talk to you like a husband
and i feel and i appreciate that how so
he's not bringing things across like how
he normally do which kind of make me
feel like oh man do i need our next
lecture
yeah
he's improving
oh that's that's good to know i'm sure a
lot of people would be happy to hear
that y'all gonna last y'all gonna last
y'all gonna last y'all ain't gonna last
how do you feel now about what jabrie
said during the tell-all
saying that he doesn't think you two are
gonna last can i see you even last i do
think they're gonna last
that comment was hilarious
well i'm glad you could laugh at it you
know because no i don't i don't play you
know i don't
i really try not to pay too much
attention to you know um even though i
know like this past season was really
really
you know like
rough you know when it relates to like
so many opinions you know because now
you know you're on a level where people
are looking at you on tv and all that
and it's hard not to look at some of
those things but after you know a couple
weeks i had to turn it out tune it out
and not look at company because
you know um there are some validity
there's to it but also you know
sometimes people you know
um they'll state their own opinion and
it's just
that you know their opinion like i said
opinion is like a news everybody has
everybody has one an opinion
yes right
so yeah
you know and um
so you know because if you let that get
the best of you it could it could
destroy you who you are etc so you don't
try to be the best that you can be and
you know it's funny that you know if you
have nowadays like if you have
you know confidence in yourself or if
you have you know back in my day you
know you just call it swag but now they
say it's your narcissist you know like
you know that's like the the word of the
the you know there's a new word now like
anything that somebody doesn't like
about you that
and it's you know it's funny because you
know i've been a type of person who's
you know as an example who has
um like
helped more women create businesses and
become business owners and entrepreneurs
and entrepreneurs you know
all around the country and and fought
and staying against domestic violence to
you know help raise money for you know
um breast cancer awareness so it's kind
of like you got to look at the whole
picture
yeah well shadow you're adored by the
internet rightfully so they love you
but
how do you feel
when what is your response i would say
to viewers who
feel as if your husband is a narcissist
or a manipulative or he uses his money
to
have power over you
what do you say to those people who ride
for you
but they're also you know
downing your choice of a husband
it's difficult because sometimes i want
to like a comment when it's oh my god i
am inspired by you i love you but i
don't like him he's a nauseous and it's
like i have to hold back and not like
that comment because i feel like if i
just press like it kind of um
i kind of solidified everything that
they're saying so it's really hard you
know i um i just want people to know
that
bilal is is a successful black male and
he has
you know he's not a dictator he's not a
manipulative quiz i will not travel all
the way from trinidad to come into a
relationship that is toxic and that is
harmful for my self especially as a yoga
instructor you know my mental health
health is very important so we do have
differences like every common
relationship we do have a little
problems here and there but i am glad
it's not the type of problems that
cheating scandals i don't have you know
i don't have to deal with those things
that other people have to deal with so
my problems i think
i'm in a position where i could handle
it and i have a husband who is looking
in the mirror now and is willing to
change you know like he
i think that's a positive element that
came out from the show you know
sometimes when you see yourself on tv
you say oh my god is that me um am i
that person so you look at you look at
you look at the mirror now and say you
know what how can i improve myself how
can i make it better for us so i'm glad
that he is willing to to you know make
those things different for us so that we
can have a healthier relationship do you
see why people come so hard for bilal
because as i mentioned in the beginning
i can say
one i can take below side for a little
moment right and all of a sudden
i feel a certain type of way about you
or i like below you know people have
these very strong feelings
about him i think um the franchise has
never seen someone like the loud before
and i think he's the first in the entire
90-day franchise
um when it comes to like having a
successful black meal who is
not dependent on getting a k1 visa to
come to america who has his own you know
he's financially responsible for himself
and he's doing well for himself so i
think he's the first
and and people are not accustomed to
seeing that so now when you see it they
take you know a negative approach
towards it that's the thing i could
think about because i think if it was a
different race i'm sorry i don't think
it would have been that bad because it
would have been like yeah that's
expected you know you know but seeing
this it's like oh this is not common for
us
so i think that could
play a factor why we hate husband
so heavy against him but you know he's
always a person and something so i guess
he's peeping anyway for other people who
look like himself to
be on your platform and i think it will
change over time yeah you know i mean
and i'll take ownership for certain
things too like you know you know can i
be condescending at times for sure but
we all have like our quirks and things
like that you know and
am i a neat freak for sure you know that
time i come from a
military you know background my father
you know so this used to structure and
used to things to be you know um can i
go overboard a little bit yeah you know
did i overreact when you know she hit me
which is so funny um
you know you get hit when you get in
trouble you know like but yeah did i
overreact yeah for sure you know i could
definitely do things better you know
um
but i think that you know also like just
giving you know people room for
improvement you know as well too and
um because we all have our own i think
part of the show is to show like
you know it's a social experiment to
show like the differences of
each other you know culturalize your
country and all these different things
and you know used to living alone for
quite a while she used to
be living with her parents you know so
like there's a lot you know on both
sides that we're trying to overcome so
there's real issues and family life and
things like that
but um you never heard me you know yell
at my wife you never heard me cuss that
much you know you never heard me demean
things like that you never
you know
throwing drinks and people you know like
and that you know teach his own but you
know to hear certain things like oh man
this is the worst person ever like those
things like wow really you know um
you know it's like because i don't like
water on the floor you know it's it's
you know it's it's it's interesting but
it's also you know things again to look
at yourself in the mirror and say okay
well all right let me try to do some
things differently but you know you're
gonna still have you know because you're
working progress you know right when
happily ever after you're gonna see that
too you're gonna see
us still because you know we filmed it
immediately right after you know 90 days
so you're going to see still that you
know it's a work in progress and we're
still you know trying to work you know
but um
yeah
we're always we're trying to improve
ourselves i think first before you know
you can improve somebody else
[Music]